we need to have the routine and we need
to have the reward and the
reward is extremely important
because if the reward is powerful
then we will remember it
[Music]
leros margalit thank you so much for
joining me on my show how are you
i'm very well thank you how are you
fantastic i'm i'm especially
good now because i'm very excited for
this talk because i'm going to learn
over these next 20 minutes
as much as i can about behavioral
economics and especially
and and building products for customers
in the digital age and i have a true
passion for behavioral economics i got
to spend
some a few months uh very close with dan
ariely at irrational labs
so i'm excited to learn about your
experiences and and you're teaching
you're also a university lecturer at the
idc for many years
and you're a strategic advisor to any
companies uh so
you know libras give me the overview who
are you and why behavioral economics
okay great um so um
as you mentioned my name is mondelez i
have a phd in psychology
i'm specialized in decision-making
processes
cognition behavioral economics and over
the past few years
i've been utilizing models from
cognitive psychology behavioral
economics and neuropsychology
to better understand how customers
behave in the digital world
and what i truly passionate about
is the differences between the online
world and the offline world
and i think that sometimes we are not
aware
but we behave completely different
online and offline
right yeah and i'm really excited to
learn
the the influences of the technology on
our behavior our emotions and
our feelings so let's go let's start
from the basics let's start from the
foundation
behavioral economics what is the study
of behavioral economics
okay so actually today we are talking
about behavioral design but
let's start with behavioral economics
and
uh we started off with an assumption
actually
uh it's a very logical assumption and
the assumption is that we are rational
human being that we
have rational decision and moreover that
we are
in control of our decisions offline and
online
and the thing is that we have a defense
mechanism
we really like to think that our
decisions
our behavior are rational
and the thing is that we are not
beginning to imagine the effect of
cognitive biases
of environmental cues of our
emotions on the way we make decisions
and you know what mika mikhail when we
are talking about the online arena
this program is getting much bigger
you know because wait lira's liras
before we get to the online
give me some examples what happens in my
day-to-day life whether it's when i go
buy
wine at the store or when i choose a
subscription for the economist paper or
or digital give me some examples of
where do i
see irrationality and i'm telling you
i'm the most irrational person i'll ever
meet you can ask my girlfriend
she'll testify for this but but but i
want you to convince
everybody else listening that we are all
irrational so let me give you two
examples two quick examples um so i work
with a company named allianz it is an
insurance company yes and you know that
they have
their policy and uh they wanted
to ask people they usually on a regular
basis ask people
um a declaration of their health
and one of these questions is um do you
smoke
and the thing is that most people
interestingly
say that they are not smoking
and um of course they are lying so we
wanted to understand
how we can make sure that people are
saying the truth
because it cost a lot of money to the
company
so i suggested to frame the question
differently so instead
of asking people do you smoke i
suggested
asking when was the last time you smoked
right what is the difference why are
those two questions
ridiculously different so the thing is
that
if i ask you when is the last time you
smoke that means that i
acknowledge the fact that you smoke and
that's fine and that's okay
and now you belong to a group of smokers
so that
makes it okay and now if i know that and
if i make you realize that i know you
are smoking
it's very hard lying about it
so that's the whole thing that's the
whole idea
of behavioral economics it's about
framing
things differently so we have the famous
question of
versky and khan man so let's say that
you decided to go to a movie
and now you decided to
buy the ticket let's say online
and you uh and you come to the movie you
come to the theater
and then you realize that you lost your
ticket what are you going
to do now bear with me
i'm going to ask this question
differently the same question
but differently okay so let's say that
you decided to see
a movie and um this time you decided
that you're not going to buy the ticket
online so you decided to go to the
theater and buy
the ticket there so you
arrive to the theater and then you open
your wallet you open up your wallet
and you found out that you are missing a
50 or i don't know 20 dollar
and then you ask yourself okay what am i
going to do
now am i going to buy another ticket so
guess what in the first scenario
people usually they are not going to buy
another ticket but in the second
scenario
they are going to buy another ticket and
why is that so why why don't why don't
they yeah
because in the first scenario they feel
like they spend like if if a ticket cost
twenty dollars they feel like they spend
thirty dollar on one
ticket but interestingly
in the second scenario they don't
correlate
the money group them together exactly in
mentally meaning so they don't associate
the money
that lost and the ticket to the theater
and then
it's fine to buy another ticket but if
we think about it
this is not a rational behavior because
we are talking about the same economics
the same amount of money yeah exactly
and and you know so whereas just like
these examples there are hundreds more
out there
that you know from from every part of
our lives so i was i was giving you know
my own example of you know going to the
wine store and
and understanding that human behavior
tends to go to purchase the the median
dollar amount for a bottle of wine but
then if marketers are
are smart about it and realize this they
can just add an extra expensive bottle
of wine at the end
and all of a sudden most customers shift
to the little bit more expensive option
but leroz i want to now steer a little
bit away from
these general behavioral economic
examples and talk a little bit more
broadly about
your work in the digital age so a lot of
these are
are tangible physical examples in our
daily lives but what is different
as we progress into the 21st century in
terms of behavioral economics and online
so um the the differences
when we're talking about our environment
the technology environment is that we
are talking about the same
effects of behavioral economic but in a
practical manner
and today we know that so many tech
companies
actually adopted those principles of
behavioral economic
but i have to say that sometimes it's
not in a very ethical way
let me give you um two examples please
so uh the first example is that to use
the same principle that we were
discussing right now and this principle
is called framing or relative thinking
and that or
anchoring um you can name it in
different ways but
the idea is that the way we frame the
decision
the way we frame the digital environment
actually is going to change our
behavior and the thing is that in the
digital
it's very very easy to change the
digital environment
and and let's say that you get up in the
morning and
you know that most people today when
they get up in the morning
the first thing that they are going to
do is to check up their smartphone to
check
up if they have new notification and let
me tell you something sometimes they do
it even in the middle of the night
and maybe they have such an important
uh notification that they have to check
it
so now let me give you an imagine and
what i'm talking about now
i like to call it the power of the
default what is the default default is
that
you open up your smartphone and you see
all those notifications but
imagine this imagine that you get up in
the morning and you see
this your smartphone your nice
smartphone says uh
good morning mikhail and
have a nice day and maybe he is going to
give you a flower or something
so these are two different ways where we
can frame your good morning environment
the reason that we choose to give you
those notifications
it's actually a message and this message
is look
all you missed when you were sleeping
and that means
don't sleep if you're going to sleep you
are going to miss
so many things so don't sleep
and of course we we don't consider this
why because we are so
used to it because behavioral design is
embedded
in a transparent way in our everyday
life so we
we didn't even give it a thought that it
things could be different
right or let's say uh the big
um let's say i would say the big
influencer of behavioral economics or
manipulator
booking.com so booking.com
has uh this way of let's say that you
are
looking up for a hotel
one room left only two rooms left act
fast
so you know all that is incredibly
fascinating and and
all these examples of behavioral
economics but you know you're a
strategic advisor to quite a few
companies
and what i'm extremely curious about is
how practically
are you do you go in and you incorporate
this academic research of behavioral
economics
into you know everyday startups because
i look at myself as a young entrepreneur
i'm going to create my own startup
now i'm very passionate about behavioral
economics so maybe i'll have a little
bit more experience and knowledge than
the average
person starting a company but but what
are what are the ways in which you come
and help these companies like you
mentioned with alliance
and what can founders and entrepreneurs
do
to become better engaged with this
content
okay great question so what i like to do
with startups
um is habit forming and by habit firming
we mean how to take a product and form a
habit habit out of it
because the thing about habits is is
really interesting because
when there is an initiate behavior and
when there is a habit
we are talking about two different brain
areas because
having is unconscious and that means
that you don't need to
think about what you are doing so let's
say you are going on facebook
sometimes we don't even consider this
this is not where we're talking about
rationality so when we are talking about
habit
this is not a rational action and this
is why
we eager to turn every behavior
every actually a set of behaviors into a
habit
so let's say that you have a new app or
why are a habit so strong by the way why
are habits so strong
okay so the thing is that our brain will
try to take
every action and turn it into a habit
because
habit does not require cognitive
resources
mental resources from our brain so when
we lock out our door when we brush our
feet in the morning
we don't we don't think about it and if
you think about it you can
lock your door and then you can think
about
like your presentation that you need to
present today to your goals and you can
think about who is going to pick up the
kids from the kindergarten
so your brain is free to think about
other tasks
and that is why habits are so important
the thing is that when um when companies
come to me they think that they can turn
every behavior
into a habit and that is not correct
because there are
behaviors that you cannot turn into a
habit and when we are talking about
habits we are
we have the habit look meaning that we
need to have a trigger to the behavior
we need to have the routine and we need
to have the reward and the
reward is extremely important
because if the reward is powerful
then we will remember it and then we
want to
actually repeat the behavior again and
we'll repeat the behavior
several times and it's not 21 days like
people like to say
it depends on the actual behavior then
the your product will become a part
of the customer's routine and this is
the holy grail
so when you go when you join us when you
join a startup as an advisor do you come
in
just one time you're just saying oh okay
you're trying to do x y z
here's the habit here's how you do it or
is it a more
thorough process along the along the way
no
um because we have many habits
every click is a habit so we need to
think about
uh the specific rewards but there is
another thing
that we need to do these days and
we are talking about personalization and
now we are in the world of
personalization and the thing about
personalization
that for so many years we are trying to
reach that point that level but i
think i really believe that on the
last two years we were able to have some
progress in personalization and by
personalization i mean that when you
walk or when you land on a website or
app you will have a different
experience compared to me right and that
means that we need to get to know our
user
and that mean that doesn't mean
demographic
i'm not talking about demographics at
all i'm talking about
personality and i'm talking about about
decision making stuff
so today i can take your facebook
profile for example and i can know who
you are
only based on your facebook your twitter
your linkedin
so actually i don't need so much
information from you
and even if you think about the
actual behavior the actual traces that
we live in the online world
we can learn so much from those traces
so let's say that you fill in a form
so i can tell using um behavioral
analytics
i can tell how you type how fast or slow
you type so if you are lying i know that
you will take slower for example
and i know if you decided to skip on a
field and then come back to it
and that means that i want to see what
you're doing and
why did you actually behave this way
and sometimes i actually plan
manipulation and let's say that there
is a button or a click that doesn't work
i like to see how people
actually click on this button meaning
that
are they uh eagerly click
one after time or are they patient
and that means a lot about their
behavior about who they are
wow this is fascinating i can ask you a
hundred more questions about this
but unfortunately i called my show 20
minute leaders so i have to uphold to
that
but i want to thank you again for for
being so generous with your time it's
been such a pleasure and an honor and
i'd love to continue learning more
from your work and and hopefully talk to
you when i have my own startup
but before we leave i need three words
that you would use to describe yourself
right so the three words are it's all
about passion
it's all about passion again it it
completely exudes through through the
screen
i love the work that you're doing i love
behavioral economics and i think it's
just so fascinating to think about
the rationality and irrationality of
human decision making
and the fact that you're taking this
into a deep dive into
the digital world and thinking
critically about how we do things i
think is remarkable so thank you very
very much and i look forward to
remaining in touch
thank you so much for inviting me bye
bye